>> ABBY, SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND JUSTICE
STEPHEN BREYER WALKING INTO THE
ROOSEVELT ROOM.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
LET ME BEGIN BY RECOGNIZING BOTH
DR. BREYER, DR. BIDEN AND FOR
BEING HERE AND I CAN'T TELL YOU,
THIS IS SORT OF A BITTERSWEET
DAY FOR ME.
JUSTICE BREYER AND I GO BACK A
LONG WAY.
ALL THE WAY BACK TO MID-'70s
WHEN HE FIRST CAME ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER STORY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS THE
NATION'S GRATITUDE TO JUSTICE
STEPHEN BREYER FOR HIS
REMARKABLE CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND HIS CLEAR-EYED
COMMITMENT TO MAKING OUR
COUNTRY'S LAWS WORK FOR ITS
PEOPLE.
AND OUR GRATITUDE EXTENDS TO
JUSTICE BREYER'S FAMILY, FOR
BEING PARTNERS IN HIS DECADES OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
PARTICULARLY I WANT TO THANK HIS
WIFE DR. JOANNE BREYER WHO IS
HERE TODAY AND WHO HAS STOOD BY
HIM FOR NEARLY SIX DECADES WITH
HER FIERCE INTELLECT, GOOD HUMOR
AND ENORMOUS HEART.
I WANT TO THANK YOU.
THE COUNTRY OWES YOU AS WELL.
AND STEPHEN BREYER'S PUBLIC
SERVICE STARTED EARLY.
HE SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY AS A TEENAGER.
AND ALL THREE BRANCHES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEFORE HE
TURNED 40.
DURING THE GOOD OLD DAYS.
AND AS HE WAS A LAW CLERK,
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE GOLDBERG.
A PROSECUTOR, A MEMBER OF THE
WATERGATE PROSECUTION TEAM.
I FIRST MET STEPHEN BREYER WHEN
I WAS A SENATOR ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, AND HE STARTED OFF AS
TAKING CARE OF ONE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEES FOR TEDDY.
AND THEN BECAME CHIEF COUNSEL
DURING HIS TENURE AS TED'S
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
BEYOND HIS INTELLECT AND HARD
WORK AND LEGAL INSIGHT, HE WAS
FAMOUS FOR BIKING ACROSS
WASHINGTON VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY
FOR FACE-TO-FACE MEETING WITH A
REPUBLICAN CHIEF COUNSEL, THE
RANKING REPUBLICAN COUNSEL AND
OVER BREAKFAST THEY DISCUSSED
WHAT WOULD THEY DO FOR THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER.
IT WAS IN THOSE DAYS WE TRIED DO
THINGS TOGETHER.
THAT SPIRIT STUCK WITH ME WHEN I
TOOK OVER THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AS CHAIR AFTER SENATOR KENNEDY'S
TENURE.
AND IT WAS MY HONOR TO VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUSTICE BREYER TO SERVE
IN THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT -- THE COURT OF APPEALS
FIRST IN 1980.
AND THEN 14 YEARS LATER, IN
1994, I GOT TO PRESIDE AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE OVER A SUPREME COURT
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS.
WE WERE JOKING WITH ONE ANOTHER
WHEN HE WALKED IN.
DID WE EVER THINK HE'D HAVE
SERVED DECADES ON THE COURT AND
I'D BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES THE DAY HE CAME IN TO
RETIRE?
AND HE LOOKED AT IT -- ANYWAY.
I WON'T SAY WHAT HE SAID,
JOKINGLY, BUT I WAS PROUD AND
GRATEFUL TO BE THERE AT THE
START OF HIS DISTINGUISHED
CAREER ON THE SUPREME COURT AND
PROUD TO BE HERE ON THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF HIS RETIREMENT.
DURING HIS CONFIRMATION HEARINGS
WAY BACK IN 1994, NOMINEE
STEPHEN BREYER SAID, QUOTE, THE
LAW MUST WORK FOR THE PEOPLE.
HE EXPLAINED TO US HIS FAITH
THAT OUR COMPLEX LEGAL SYSTEM
HAS A SINGLE PURPOSE.
TELL PEOPLE WHO MAKE UP OUR
COUNTRY.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT TIME, OF
COURSE.
BUT HIS BRILLIANCE, VALUE AND
SCHOLARSHIP ARE WHY JUDGE BREYER
BECAME JUSTICE BREYER BY AN
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN VOTE AT
THE TIME.
TODAY, JUSTICE BREYER ANNOUNCES
HIS INTENTION TO STEP DOWN FROM
ACTIVE SERVICE AFTER FOUR
DECADES.
FOUR DECADES ON THE FEDERAL
BENCH AND 28 YEARS ON THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
HIS LEGACY INCLUDES HIS WORK AS
A LEADING SCHOLAR AND JURIST IN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW, BRINGING HIS
BRILLIANCE TO BEAR TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT RUN MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY.
IT INCLUDES HIS STATURE AS A
BEACON OF WISDOM ON OUR
CONSTITUTION AND WHAT IT MEANS.
AND THROUGH IT ALL, JUSTICE
BREYER'S WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
GIVE FAITH TO THE NOTION THAT
THE LAW EXISTS TO HELP THE
PEOPLE.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT STEPHEN
BREYER HAS BEEN AN EXEMPLARY
JUSTICE.
FAIR TO THE PARTIES BEFORE HIM,
COURTEOUS TO HIS COLLEAGUES,
CAREFUL IN HIS REASONING.
HE'S WRITTEN LANDMARK OPINIONS
ON TOPICS FROM REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS TO HEALTH CARE, VOTING
RIGHTS, PATENT LAW, LAWS
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
THE LAWS THAT PROTECT OUR
RELIGIOUS PRACTICES.
HIS OPINIONS ARE PRACTICAL,
SENSIBLE AND NUANCED.
REFLECTS HIS BELIEF THAT A JOB
OF A JUDGE IS NOT TO LAY DOWN A
RULE BUT TO GET IT RIGHT.
TO GET IT RIGHT.
JUSTICE BREYER'S LAW CLERKS AND
COLLEAGUES, AS MANY IN THE PRESS
KNOW, DESCRIBE HIM AND HIS WORK
ETHIC, HIS DESIRE TO LEARN MORE.
HIS KINDNESS TO THOSE AROUND HIM
AND HIS OPTIMISM FOR THE PROMISE
OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND HE HAS PATIENTLY SOUGHT
COMMON GROUND AND BUILT
CONSENSUS, SEEKING TO BRING THE
COURT TOGETHER.
I THINK HE'S A MODEL PUBLIC
SERVANT AT A TIME OF GREAT
DIVISION IN THIS COUNTRY.
JUSTICE BREYER HAS BEEN
EVERYTHING HIS COUNTRY COULD
HAVE ASKED OF HIM.
AND HE'S APPEARED BEFORE -- WHEN
HE APPEARED BEFORE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ALMOST THREE DECADES
AGO, WE ALL HAD HIGH HOPES FOR
THE MARK HE'D LEAVE ON HISTORY,
THE LAW AND CONSTITUTION.
HE'S EXCEEDED THOSE HOPES IN
EVERY POSSIBLE WAY.
TODAY IS HIS DAY.
OUR DAY TO COMMEND HIS LIFE OF
SERVICE AND HIS LIFE ON THE
COURT.
BUT LET ME SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WORK OF
SELECTING HIS SUCCESSOR.
CHOOSING SOMEONE TO SIT ON THE
SUPREME COURT, I BELIEVE, IS ONE
OF THE MOST SERIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
A PRESIDENT HAS.
OUR PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
RIGOROUS.
I WILL SELECT THE NOMINEE WORTHY
OF JUSTICE BREYER'S LEGACY OF
EXCELLENCE AND DECENCY.
WHILE I'VE BEEN STUDYING
CANDIDATES' BACKGROUNDS AND
WRITINGS, I'VE MADE NO DECISION
EXCEPT ONE.
THE PERSON I WILL NOMINATE WILL
BE SOMEONE OF EXTRAORDINARY
QUALIFICATIONS, CHARACTER,
EXPERIENCE AND INTEGRITY.
AND THAT PERSON WILL BE THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN EVER NOMINATED
TO THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT.
IT'S LONG OVERDUE IN MY OPINION.
I MADE THAT COMMITMENT DURING
THE CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT, AND
I WILL KEEP THAT COMMITMENT.
I WILL FULLY DO WHAT I SAID I'D
DO.
I WILL FULFILL MY DUTY TO SELECT
A JUSTICE NOT ONLY WITH THE
SENATE'S CONSENT BUT WITH ITS
ADVICE.
YOU HEARD ME SAY ANOTHER
NOMINATION PROCESSES THAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS SEEK THE
ADVICE AND CONSENT.
BUT THE ADVICE AS WELL OF THE
SENATE.
I'M GOING TO INVITE SENATORS
FROM BOTH PARTIES TO OFFER THEIR
IDEAS AND POINTS OF VIEW.
I'LL ALSO CONSULT WITH LEADING
SCHOLARS AND LAWYERS.
AND I AM FORTUNATE TO HAVE
ADVISING ME, VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE'S AN EXCEPTIONAL LAWYER,
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, FORMER
MEMBER OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I WILL LISTEN CAREFULLY TO ALL
THE ADVICE I'M GIVEN, AND I'LL
STUDY THE RECORDS AND FORMER
CASES CAREFULLY.
I'LL MEET WITH THE POTENTIAL
NOMINEES AND IT'S MY INTENTION,
MY INTENTION TO ANNOUNCE MY
DECISION BEFORE THE END OF
FEBRUARY.
I HAVE MADE NO CHOICE AT THIS
POINT.
ONCE I SELECT A NOMINEE, I'LL
ASK THE SENATE TO MOVE PROMPTLY
ON MY CHOICE.
IN THE END, I WILL NOMINATE AN
HISTORIC CANDIDATE, SOMEONE WHO
IS WORTHY OF JUSTICE BREYER'S
LEGACY, AND SOMEONE WHO, LIKE
JUSTICE BREYER, WILL PROVIDE
INCREDIBLE SERVICE ON THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
JUSTICE BREYER, ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND
YOUR FAMILY FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS
SERVICE TO OUR NATION.
I'M GOING TO YIELD THE FLOOR TO
YOU, MR. JUSTICE.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
TERRIBLY NICE, AND BELIEVE ME, I
HOLD IT RIGHT HERE.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT I MIGHT
SAY TO YOU, AND I'D LIKE TO
SAY -- SOMETHING I ENJOY IS
TALKING TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
GRAMMAR SCHOOL STUDENTS.
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
EVEN LAW SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AND THEY'LL COME AROUND AND ASK
ME, WHAT IS THE -- WHAT IS IT
YOU FIND PARTICULARLY MEANINGFUL
ABOUT YOUR JOB?
WHAT GIVES YOU A THRILL?
AND THAT'S NOT SUCH A TOUGH
QUESTION FOR ME TO ANSWER.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
DAY ONE, ALMOST, UP TO DAY, I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY, BUT THE --
WHAT I SAY TO THEM IS, LOOK, I
SIT THERE ON THE BENCH AND AFTER
WE HEAR LOTS OF CASES, AND AFTER
AWHILE, THE IMPRESSION, IT TAKES
AWHILE, I HAVE TO ADMIT, BUT THE
IMPRESSION YOU GET IS YOU KNOW,
AS YOU WELL KNOW, THIS IS A
COMPLICATED COUNTRY.
MORE THAN 330 MILLION PEOPLE.
THEY USED TO SAY IT'S EVERY
RACE, EVERY RELIGION AND SHE'D
EMPHASIZE THIS AND IT'S EVERY
POINT OF VIEW POSSIBLE.
AND IT'S A KIND OF MIRACLE WHEN
YOU SIT THERE AND SEE ALL THOSE
PEOPLE IN FRONT OF YOU.
PEOPLE THAT ARE SO DIFFERENT IN
WHAT THEY THINK.
AND YET THEY DECIDED TO HELP
SOLVE THEIR MAJOR DIFFERENCES
UNDER LAW.
AND WHEN THE STUDENTS GET TOO
CYNICAL I SAY GO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS IN COUNTRIES THAT DON'T
DO THAT.
AND THAT'S -- PEOPLE HAVE COME
TO ACCEPT THIS CONSTITUTION AND
THEY'VE COME TO ACCEPT THE
IMPORTANCE OF A RULE OF LAW.
AND I WANT TO MAKE ANOTHER POINT
TO THEM.
I WANT TO SAY, LOOK, OF COURSE
PEOPLE DON'T AGREE.
BUT WE HAVE A COUNTRY THAT IS
BASED ON HUMAN RIGHTS, DEMOCRACY
AND SO FORTH.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHAT LINCOLN
THOUGHT, WHAT WASHINGTON THOUGHT
AND WHAT PEOPLE TODAY STILL
THINK.
IT'S AN EXPERIMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID.
AND JOANNA PAID EACH OF OUR
GRANDCHILDREN A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF MONEY TO MEMORY RISE THE
GETTYSBURG ADDRESS AND THE
REASON -- THE REASON THAT WHAT
WE WANT THEM TO PICK UP THERE
AND WHAT I WANT THOSE STUDENTS
TO PICK UP, IF I CAN REMEMBER
THE FIRST TWO LINES IS THAT FOUR
SCORE AND SEVEN YEARS AGO OUR
FATHERS BROUGHT -- CREATED UPON
THIS HERE A NEW COUNTRY.
A COUNTRY THAT WAS DEDICATED TO
LIBERTY AND THE PROPOSITION THAT
ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
CONCEIVED IN LIBERTY.
THOSE ARE HIS WORDS.
AND DEDICATED TO THE PROPOSITION
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
HE MEANT IT.
AND NOW WE'RE ENGAGED IN A GREAT
CIVIL WAR.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THAT NATION
OR ANY NATION SO CONCEIVED AND
SO DEDICATED CAN LONG ENDURE.
SEE, THOSE ARE THE WORDS I WANT
TO SEE.
AN EXPERIMENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE THOUGHT.
IT'S AN EXPERIMENT.
AND I FOUND SOME LETTERS THAT
GEORGE WASHINGTON WROTE WHERE HE
SAID THE SAME THING.
IT'S AN EXPERIMENT.
THAT EXPERIMENT EXISTED THEN
BECAUSE EVEN THE LIBERALS IN
EUROPE, THEY ARE LOOKING OVER
HERE AND SAYING, IT'S A GREAT
IDEA IN PRINCIPLE, BUT IT WILL
NEVER WORK.
BUT WE'LL SHOW THEM IT DOES.
THAT'S WHAT WASHINGTON THOUGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT LINCOLN THOUGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE STILL
THINK TODAY.
AND I SAY, ALL I WANT YOU, AND
I'M TALKING TO THE STUDENTS NOW,
I SAY I WANT YOU TO PICK JUSTICE
UP.
IT'S AN EXPERIMENT THAT'S GOING
ON AND I'LL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW WHO WILL SEE WHETHER
THAT EXPERIMENT WORKS?
IT'S YOU, MY FRIEND.
IT'S YOU, MR. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT.
IT'S YOU, MR. COLLEGE STUDENT.
IT'S YOU, MR. LAW SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
IT'S US, BUT IT'S YOU.
IT'S THAT NEXT GENERATION.
AND THE ONE AFTER THAT.
MY GRANDCHILDREN AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
THEY'LL DETERMINE WHETHER THE
EXPERIMENT STILL WORKS AND, OF
COURSE, I'M AN OPTIMIST AND I AM
PRETTY SURE IT WILL.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU THA